local students form after-school
douchebag Club a group of students at a
Pennsylvania high school organized an
anti-gay protests by dressing in
matching flannels posting Bible verses
on lockers and wearing the word anti-gay
on their hands this protest came after a
day of silence a school event held to
recognize gay bullying students who
participated in the Day of Silence event
reported being verbally and physically
harassed by the flannel-wearing students
the superintendent took to a local news
station addressing the severity of this
issue
ensuring necessary actions will be taken
to eliminate discrimination within the
school system all right so first off I
should just tell these guys that flannel
is a staple in the lesbian community so
they may have been dressing up like
lesbians or the Bears the gay bears wear
a lot of flannel so that they screwed up
the the dress code of this club
lumberjack and he's okay yeah exactly
flannels back among the hipster crowd a
lot of gay hipsters a lot of games yeah
but so yes they created this Club we're
just a couple dudes were hanging out
together we're and final that seems kind
of gay to me what wait you know the
footage of them all you know circle
jerking each other video comes out it's
over that no one not closeted hates gays
that much no one that's the rule you go
there you must stop all gays that's the
he says in the mirror every morning
when he okay so that that's my
that's basically the whole crux of this
whole story is right like this is Klaus
this is just sad the rule it's the
universal unavoidable rule I don't think
so when I argue this every time we've
we've had this debate before I think
that that your talk growing up about to
fear again we talked about fear in
another clip today to be afraid of
different and gay is different and gay
and we're afraid to talk about sex to
begin with so we're already timid and a
little Victorian about sex and then this
is the big sex thing right it's this is
really different and parents and
unfortunately pastors and all kinds of
youth leaders are telling these kids
that this is dangerous and somehow this
is corrupting so yeah
sure some of these kids might be
closeted but I think there is a
willingness and an eagerness to hate and
to defend the thing that again that your
parents have told you was slipping away
the idea of the great idyllic America
when black people couldn't ride in the
front of the bus you know and there was
two black baseball players but you know
that again they and they already feel
like they've lost a lot like ah what the
blacks already have they're everywhere
and they're protesting and they're angry
all the time why can't we take what's
ours
why are they in Croke they're
encroaching they're taking for me even
though they're not and I think it has I
think that has a lot to do with it
separate from whether that whatever they
secretly feel at night when they're home
the beautiful part of the story I
suppose is that the internet exists now
and these kids can be exposed and that
this stuff won't everybody not the head
of posts next to the dead giraffe you're
done you
you dunce you just blew it while
you're going hey hey look at ID why does
my life suck now why am i miserable and
drinking cuz you showed earth and you
live in a bubble this big you live in a
Habitrail tool tube and when you come
out of that tube you see how everyone's
looking at you and saw what you did
their minds are being blown they're all
completely isolated but then aren't you
then bullying those guys they're just
trying to stand up for what they believe
in aren't you a big left-wing bully I
care less about bullying than some
people I like I don't I think that part
of it
toughen you up I think that when it's
directed at a specific group it's
obviously dangerous and schools need to
do something about it I do worry about
keeping these kids from expressing their
point of view but they need to be outed
oddly enough uh for being the sort of
vitriolic haters that they are notice
that they're no girls doing that there's
only these idiot guys there look to be
about seven or eight of them and they
and they you know and BuzzFeed where I
think that article came from they tie
lies the the photos of the guys and I
think that was the right thing for them
to do but in that community McGuffey
high school uh the uh you know that
everybody knows and
but he knows who they are yeah so yeah
and that's what they'll say because
again part of this thing is is if you're
sort of white and Christian and
everything's fine but you don't have
quite as much power and influence as you
used to the new idea again echoed by by
Fox consistently and by Limbaugh on the
radio is that you're the victims so
these guys have somehow felt because
there was a Gay Pride Day the day before
where kids who were different and it
felt isolated most of their life stood
up and said I just want to I just want
to be able to go to high school and be
myself I asked for nothing more than to
be able to go to ice gonna be myself
that somehow these guys have been led to
believe again by their parents sometimes
by lousy pastors and by mass right-wing
media that somehow that is a threat to
their way of life the whole anti-gay
thing is just basically they're useful
idiots being used to keep the production
line moving forward of new customers
because gays don't produce new
Christians yeah even though Christians
continually produce new gays are you a
Christian producing a game let us know
in the comments write down to them